inauguré en 1969 la délégation du québec
à chicago couvre le territoire des 12
états du midwest américain
la nouvelle déléguée martine hébert
ancienne vice présidente principale de
la fédération canadienne de l'entreprise
indépendante est en poste depuis
quelques semaines nous l'avons rencontré
hier martine hébert bonjour bonjour un
plaisir de vous revoir
n'est ce pas vous savez combien de mois
maintenant que vous êtes à chicago en
fait je suis arrivé à chicago depuis est
vraiment le début septembre seulement
oui comment ça se voit ça se passe très
bien
voudrait que c'est un univers fascinant
vous savez et le midwest américain aussi
qui est une région qu'on connaît très
peu quand on pense aux exportations aux
états unis on pense à new york on passe
à des grands ensembles comme se met
vraiment la région du midwest est très
riche à la fois au niveau du potentiel
pour nos entreprises et à la fois aussi
à différents égards pour l'économie
québécoise et donc vous faites rayonner
c'est la suite de ce que vous faisiez
dans le fond à la fédération de
l'entreprise indépendante là vous voulez
faire rayonner les entreprises d'ici à
chicago absolument et vous savez le
premier ministre ado l'idée mandat très
clair aux délégations le premier mandat
c'est d'attirer davantage
d'investissements étrangers au québec
donc des entreprises qui sont sur le
territoire là bas les convaincre de
venir investir au québec d'une part et
par ailleurs augmenter les exportations
des entreprises québécoises là dans les
états américains dont ceux du midwest
qui sont très importants d'ailleurs
parce qu'on le sait pas mais 25% des
exportations du québec à peu près là
s'en vont aux états unis s'en vont dans
le midwest n'ont à peu près 15 milliards
d'exportations québécoises qui sont
kitty qui ont lieu dans le midwest
américain
donc c'est quand même très important est
ce que votre mission et les 100%
économique dans un sens c'est à dire que
oui le gros de la mission du recentrage
ou fait aussi des délégations l'heure
est à caractère économique ça c'est très
clair
évidemment on a d'autres mandats aussi
par exemple au niveau culturel on reçoit
le reçu le sm la semaine prochaine on
reçoit leurs caisses métropolitaine
montréal mais ça demeure quand même un
marginal je vous dirai dans l'ensemble
des activités de la délégation ckoi donc
le potentiel de chicago de l'ohio et des
autres états qui sont environnants
on parle souvent de l'état de new york
ici on parle du commerce avec les
états-unis en général du commerce
mondial pour le québec mais votre région
à vous c'est quoi son potentiel pour les
entreprises du québec
c'est énorme je vous dirais que c'est
une très grosse région c'est le coeur
manufacturier en fait des etats unis
c'est le midwest américain d'une part à
peu près 20% de la population américaine
où c'est dans l'humiliation perte de 68
millions de personnes qui sont étaient
membres d'entreprises d'autre du canada
tout à fait beaucoup d'entreprises dans
le fortune 500 comme kraft par exemple
tracteurs et quand on parle des états
unis s'il faut se rendre compte qu'on
parle de quelque chose d'énorme ans
comparativement ici d'un exemple par
exemple je regardais le cros girl à la
chaîne d'alimentation américaine
c'est des milliers de magasins dans 35
états au pays
121 milliards de ventes donc lorsqu'on
réussit à pénétrer dans des marchés
comme ça pour des entreprises dans le
domaine agro alimentaire par exemple
ceux des marchés potentiels qui sont qui
sont je vous dirais incroyable tout à
fait mais est-ce que c'est sous-exploité
de la peur du québec parce qu'en même
temps la proximité géographique n'est
pas exactement là ça reste un petit peu
loin de l'eau du québec
oui mais c'est très accessible parce que
justement le chicago site un centre
logistique très important c'est
accessible notamment par par la voie
maritime avec les grands lacs au niveau
ferroviaire aussi c'était très important
puis évidemment l'aéroport de chicago
est quand même un aéroport très
important donc je vous dirais qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de débouchés
potentiels pour les entreprises
québécoises sont les entreprises
québécoises qui sont bien présentes
chicago en fait il y en a dans le
midwest américain vous avez des
entreprises qui sont établis la boj
passe à saputo par exemple je pense à
agropur qui ont des usines à couche tard
qui ont fait des acquisitions
importantes aussi bombardier évidemment
mais il ya d'autres entreprises comme à
chicago il ya le groupe la casquette un
fabricant de meubles qui est un salon de
démonstration là ce qu'on appelle donc
il ya beaucoup d'entreprises comme ça il
ya des entreprises aussi qui va
évidemment leurs produits puisque on
exporte je pensais à tout de ce lyon là
ministre giraud enfin une mission en
février dernier qui a débouché sur un
contrat d'autobus électriques dans le
michigan pour autre but si lyon
justement donc ce genre de potentiel
là aussi et ça qu'on crée ce qu'on est
prêt à exporter davantage c'est à dire
que oui moi je pense que beaucoup
d'entreprises québécoises qui gagnerait
à connaître le midwest parce que il ya
des opportunités dans des villes où
comme minneapolis par exemple 5,6 nati
qui sont des endroits où il ya peut-être
moins de compétition il ya peut-être
moins deux fournisseurs en lice le pot
fournir les équipements ou encore les
matières premières que recherchent les
entreprises dans ces villes là donc il
ya si vous voulez yola je pense une
belle voix pour nos entreprises ya
encore beaucoup de marge de manoeuvre
évidemment le défi pour une entreprise
du québec c'est toujours d'être devoir
faire un diagnostic préalable mais
ceux-ci experts québec qui nous aident à
faire ça pour s'assurer que l'entreprise
est prête à exporter qu'elle va être
capable de livrer la marchandise aussi
entre vous et moi
est-ce qu'on vous parle de donald trump
à ce que ça vient interférer dans la
relation entre le québec et l'idée
d'investir par exemple dans la région de
royan c'est à dire que c'est sûr que le
protectionnisme américain inquiète les
entreprises les entreprises regardent ça
de près et c'est normal je suis cassé il
ya de ça parce que les états unis
demeurent quand même notre principal
partenaire commercial
mais je voudrais que dans mon quotidien
la danse que j'ai fait comme activités
cette semaine par exemple avec des
entreprises manufacturières qui était à
chicago pour l'événement fabrique qui
est un événement du manufacturier 9 ans
ou encore la semaine passée avec
d'autres entreprises là dans le domaine
des sciences de la vie à toledo
c'est pas des conversations
nécessairement qu'on a tous les risques
les entreprises québec se sentent bien
venu compte tenu du protectionnisme
américain ce qu'ils se sentent bien ce
qu'elle se sente bien venue de
l'investir aux états unis je voudrais
qu'elle jusqu'à présent oui je peux je
voudrais que moi les entreprises
québécoises qu'elle voit c'est le
potentiel mieux du potentiel il ya un
marché potentiel commentait ce que je
fais pour pénétrer ce marché là et le
rôle des délégations de la délégation
s'est entre autres justement de trouver
des clients potentiels de les mettre en
lien nos entreprises québécoises avec
ses clients potentiels là sur le
territoire et c'est assez facile est ce
que vous vous êtes donné un objectif
personnel
ben oui
j'ai vraiment l'objectif de de faire en
sorte que effectivement il ya plus
d'entreprises québécoises qui exportent
et d'explorer certaines filières
davantage que ce soit non seulement dans
le domaine par exemple de
l'agroalimentaire mais aussi dans
certains secteurs stratégiques comme le
transport électrique ou au québec on a
des forces et il ya un gros potentiel
dans les états américains qu'on couvre
parce qu'il ya vraiment une mouvance
vers le transport électrique
d'ailleurs hier j'étais en rencontre
avec city et chicago transit authority
qui justement achète les flottes de
véhicules d'autobus
on sait qu'on a des bon consultant de
tomber sur des critiques au québec donc
c'est ce genre de diplomatie économique
là si vous voulez le coeur on réalise au
quotidien moyen qui permet
éventuellement de déboucher sur un sort
des contrats pour nous entre eux on
retrouve votre enthousiasme pour les
entreprises très clairement merci
martine hébert et à la prochaine
merci à vous